[Musica]
ma rimarca ancora per salire al quarto
piano 1 per ascoltare lo so che che
passi il primo il secondo il terzo
bianco vestiti cadavere con una gran
corsa nella soffitta di casa mondo
l'uomo da nove mesi in quanto memoria
tra nove mesi si chiama in bond
una cosa mi può fare un favore a salire
dal balcone e magari come pietra spacca
è vero mentre il caso secondo la bbc
[Musica]
eccomi signore
senti rientro a casa adesso vai di
saluto un bacio dai 100 ci si chiama
ciao io sono tutto casa chiesa che sono
peggio c'è qualcuno che ci vuole per i
master in e alla fine un pochino la
lista di tutte le cose con visto un
interruttore per analogo motivo garanzia
come sia una valigia in quella di stata
la prima valigia
ti ho lasciato dentro la diciamo come la
valigia sapore del sale sapore bene
e lo sappiano
questa qui per i vestiti e prescritta
una grossa per il mio non mi chiamo il
mio migliore amico quando mi manca ok
ragazzi non ho già avuto una così a casa
ma tiene
infatti un'altra cosa
i soldi nel caos
[Applauso]
ma perché nessuno ha mai fronte di circa
perché perché rischiamo la valigia
puzza di mourinho ma il nocciolo subito
locale
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ok magliette mangiano disinfestare tutto
quanto abbiamo fuori
finalmente a casa finalmente uno
specchio pole era quanto ci sentiamo
senti ti chiamo perché devono dare un
parere è che non mi ha assolutamente
chiesto scusa il secondo è dicevo allora
è sempre secondo me tu sbagli nella vita
la valigia per gli altri la regia con il
vostro nome
la valigia con i sindacati già per le
mutande capo la valigia del bus e il
borsone del buon gusto più come si
permette di saltarmi ritorno delle
vacanze e salutano 0 mercoledì 09 che si
chiama come si chiama isabella la mia
morte violenta
poi già martino come stai tutto bene ti
possa cadere in favore ti spiace se
riprendiamo il litigio che abbiamo
iniziato un mese fa e che non mi sono
per niente legato al dito dai ok a testa
di cane o un pochino che fa una mia ex
elementari ma se n'è fatta una vita mm
che rimarrebbero sono stati messi sotto
processo
[Musica]
andate via
chiama la volontà ma scusi questo qui
scusa ho sbagliato indiano si lanciano
ecco dove la casa porta buoni dolci
ecco una scelta sono pronto sì ciao ciao
ciao come stai
accetto che ho capito che sei mamma che
piacere essere a casa
chiamo il mio amico mio caro amico molto
divertente ciao chiamo altro mio amico
nozzo non solo fanno mondo
finalmente qualcosa e l'incanto come il
mio cuore che giornata carica di
emozioni
[Musica]
apollo l ora del delitto che verrebbero
scolare l'acqua della mamma che l'hanno
poi anche di davide votato racconta di
guida
[Musica]
la valigia che questo viaggio insieme
facciamo un nemico si no e adesso che mi
sono riposato brandao va bene va bene
adesso andiamo a dire su questa città ho
voglia di dormire quel silenzio classe
stai tranquillo non la prima si chiuse
ma dai su serino basterebbe un bel
respiro e sartoni stand in gara
[Musica]
[Risate]